GRIFF: YOU HAVE PROBABLY SEEN
THIS VIDEO SHOWING SMUGGLERS
DROPPING YOUNG CHILDREN JUST 3
AND 5 YEARS OLD 14 FEET OVER A
BORDER WALL AND ABANDONING THEM
IN THE NEW MEXICO DESERT.
THE BORDER CHIEF JOINED ME NOW,
THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME, WHEN
YOU SAW THIS VIDEO WHAT WAS YOUR
INITIAL REACTION AND WHY HAVE
YOU RELEASED IT?
>> THANK YOU FOR COVERING THIS
STORY.
FOR US THESE ARE THE TACTICS WE
SEE FROM SMUGGLERS ON THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER.
WHEN I SAW THE IMAGES PROVIDED
BY MY STAFF I COULD NOT BELIEVE
WHAT I WAS WATCHING.
I WAS HORRIFIED.
I WAS APPALLED TO SEE THAT YOUNG
CHILD DROPPED LIKE THAT FROM A
14 FOOT BARRIER TO THE GROUND IN
AN AREA WHERE IT IS SO ROCKY AND
MOUNTAINS AND REMOTE, THE CHILD
FOR A FEW SECONDS DIDN’T MOVE SO
I WAS VERY WORRIED UNTIL I
STARTED SEEING HER MOVEMENT,
THEN I SAW A SECOND CHILD
DROPPED OFF THAT BARRIER AND THE
THIRD ITEM THROWN OVER THE FENCE
AND THEY ABANDONED THESE
CHILDREN AND RAN UP THE HILL AND
RUN AWAY WITHOUT CARING FOR THE
WELFARE OF THOSE CHILDREN OR ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT BARRIER.
GRIFF: THE CARTELS BEHIND THIS,
YOU WANT TO PURSUE THESE TWO
SMUGGLERS BUT IN TERMS OF THE
BIGGER PICTURE IS THIS
INDICATIVE?
>> IT IS AND I DON’T THINK -- I
HEARD THE COMMENTS OF THE
SECRETARY THE OTHER DAY SO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
ALL THE WAY TO THE FRONT LINE
BORDER PATROL AGENTS WE ALL KNOW
THESE SMUGGLERS ARE VERY
RUTHLESS.
THEY DO HUGE EXPLOITATION OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF A SITUATION WHEN IT
COMES TO HUMAN BEINGS AND IT IS
INHUMANE TREATMENT OF A HUMAN
BEING.
YOU HAVE BEEN ALONG THE BORDER
IN EL PASO STRETCHING FROM FORT
HANCOCK, TEXAS ALL THE WAY TO
NEW MEXICO.
THERE ARE AREAS WHERE CHILDREN
ARE WALKING UP TO THE BORDER
CROSSING WHERE THERE IS NO
BARRIER SO WHY TAKE THESE
INNOCENT LITTLE GIRLS 3 YEARS
AND 5 YEARS OLD TO AN AREA IN
NEW MEXICO WHERE THERE IS A 14
FOOT BARRIER AND DROP THEM FROM
THE TOP OF IT WHEN CLEARLY THERE
WAS ANOTHER AREA WHERE THEY WERE
GOING TO PUSH THESE GIRLS TO THE
US SIDE THEY COULD HAVE WALKED
THROUGH AN OPEN AREA WHERE THERE
WAS NO NEED.
>> IN YOUR 264 MILES IT IS ROUGH
TERRAIN AND THIS IS VERY
TELLING.
IT CAPTURES THE BRUTALITY OF
THIS CRISIS.
LET ME ASK YOU, THERE IS THE
PUSH FACTOR IN THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE OF POVERTY AND
VIOLENCE, PARENTS WOULD CONSIDER
ALLOWING THEIR CHILDREN TO MAKE
THIS DANGEROUS JOURNEY.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THEM?
>> MY INTENT WITH THIS VIDEO WAS
TO GET THIS OUT THERE SO THAT
THE PARENTS WITH THIS
ARRANGEMENT OF CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS OR OTHER PEOPLE
THAT ARE ENCOURAGING THIS TO
UNDERSTAND WHEN THEY TURN OVER
THEIR CHILDREN TO PEOPLE LIKE
THIS THESE PEOPLE DON’T CARE
ABOUT THEIR WELL-BEING.
THEY TREAT THESE CHILDREN AS A
COMMODITY IN THE MOMENT THEY
TURN A CHILD IN, WHETHER IT IS
ECUADOR OR GUATEMALA OR THE
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES, THE
EXPLOITATION STARTS FROM THAT
MOMENT ON THROUGHOUT THE
JOURNEY.
I WONDER WHEN I VISITED WITH
THESE LITTLE GIRLS, SO CONCERNED
ABOUT THEM.
I WANT TO THE CENTRAL PROCESSING
CENTER WHERE WE ARE HOLDING
CHILDREN AND I WANTED TO SEE
THEM.
THEY WERE SO TALKATIVE BUT I WAS
STANDING THERE AND WONDERED IF
THEY WERE TALKING TO ME WHAT
KIND OF EXPERIENCES THEY WENT
THROUGH FROM ECUADOR THAT WE
DON’T KNOW ABOUT.
THEY WERE THE ONES BEING CARRIED
BY THESE RUTHLESS SMUGGLERS WITH
INHUMANE TREATMENT OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION.
GRIFF: A QUESTION ON AN
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF CHILDREN
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER, ONE
REPORT, 180,000.
ARE YOU HEARING ANYTHING ON WHAT
WE MIGHT SEE THIS YEAR?
>> OPERATORS ON THE BORDER, AN
OVERWHELMING SITUATION, AND
BORDER REGIONS ARE DOING A
PHENOMENAL JOB.
THEY ARE TRYING TO KEEP UP WITH
THE FLOW.
WE ARE GOING TO SURPASS FOR THE
EL PASO SECTOR THE NUMBERS FROM
2019 AND WE HAD A SURGE
SITUATION OF PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER 182,000 PEOPLE
WE ENDED UP APPREHENDING THAT
YEAR.
GRIFF: THANK YOU FOR TAKING